India has halted production at a
pharmaceutical Factory after cough
medicine produced there was linked to
the deaths of children in The Gambia the
health Minister for the state of haryana
says the facility violated several
protocols it follows a medical alert
issued by the World Health Organization
last week well the who warned cough
syrups Made in India could be linked to
the deaths of nearly 70 children in the
West African State lab samples showed
the medicine was contaminated
Well India is the world's largest
exporter of generic drugs but its
regulatory structure is widely seen as
inadequate the framework has been
criticized for being fragmented and
disorganized with the central Authority
lacking autonomy and with dozens of
state regulators and health departments
coordination is difficult well this has
led to poor enforcement or rules on
drugs and the lack of accountability
well let's bring in that Prashant ready
he's a lawyer and co-author of the truth
pill the myth of drug regulation in
India he joins us from New Delhi welcome
to the program now this latest issue in
The Gambia is not the first such or
similar controversy is it
thank you
yes you're right unfortunately since
1972 we recorded at least five such uh
mass casualty events due to other traded
cough syrup uh and for example in 1998
33 children died on the outskirts of
Delhi the most recent event in India was
in January 2020 where 12 children died
from the region of Jammu because that
consumed adulterated crops syrup so yes
you're right this is unfortunately not
something new to the Indian
pharmaceutical industry it's been a
repeated problem
so why does the regulatory system in
India appear to be so fragmented why is
this
well I mean this is the Indian drug
regulatory law is a very old law it was
enacted in 1940 when India was still a
British colony
and it hasn't changed much since then so
we have a system of having a regulator
for every state in Union territory which
licenses manufacturing plus we have a
central regulator which takes care of
imports and Drug approvals so at the end
of the day India has around 38
Regulators with limited jurisdictions
that are limited to their own States and
a lot of Bad actors slipped through the
cracks now since the since 1954 the
government has been trying to
consolidate this this entire framework
and create a more uh unified Visa
regulator but it's important to
understand that the Indian
pharmaceutical industry is a very
powerful entity within the country and a
lot of them are completely against a
more unified system because they know
that would increase uh the quality and
efficiency of Regulation and perhaps
then also its costs of manufacturing
drugs uh so we presume that opposition
from the industry is one of the main
reasons that we don't have a more
cohesive unified regulatory structure in
India but the government in India might
say look in this particular case all
production at the factory has been
stopped and more action might be taken
so something is being done
well I mean that's a little too late
right after 66 uh dead children but we
have been my co-authorp the new Chicago
India today with us we have been
researching about this company ever
since the Scandal broke out last week
because during the course of researching
this book we created our own database of
information
and we found several instances where the
same company accused of uh the tragedy
in Gambia has been
hauled up by Indian dog by different uh
state governments within India and
apparently it was also blacklisted by
the Vietnamese Vietnamese government uh
in 2014 or 2016. one of those two years
so this Con this company had a history
of basically being hauled up and we've
seen this pattern play out because the
company that was accused of the tragedy
in Jammu North India and 2020 which
killed 12 children
was flagged 19 times according to
Independent reporting by different
Regulators within the Indian state
so these kind these companies keep
escaping serious liability
and they finally come to a stage where
they commit a rose error which leads to
tragedies like this okay okay that that
said forgive me for interrupting that
said countries that accept these drugs
though shouldn't they play a role in
this some kind of responsibility as well
well yes I'm so typically the U.S and
Europeans who have well-funded
Regulators send over their inspectors to
inspect Indian plants before they can
manufacture and Export to those
territories but a lot of African
countries simply don't have the
resources to do so and Indian
manufacturers unfortunately know that
which is why they export substandard
medicine to those countries in fact
there have been even an academic paper
that came out six seven years ago which
said exactly this that drugs Indian
drugs that were drawn from the African
market and tested failed at a higher
rate than drugs that were taken from
other better regulated markets okay okay
we leave it there pressure and ready we
very much appreciate your insights here
today thank you
thank you